[Musique]
bonjour à tous
et bienvenue donc sur cette première
plénière dématérialisée de de nos
universités de rentrée
je me présente en deux mots je suis
françois xavier pénicaud élu local
adjoint au maire de bron et conseiller
régional en ouvert mon âme alors sur ce
sujet de la reconquête des territoires
qu'on va être amené à traiter ensemble
pendant une heure ils se situent ce
contexte on début de nos universités de
rentrée dans un contexte de morcellement
de la société qui a largement été décrit
ces dernières années qui est un morceau
mouvements parfois décrit de façon sous
un angle à la fois sociales parfois
économique d'opposition entre nos
territoires mais aussi de belles
opportunités de réconciliation nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans un contexte
aussi de débats très fort sur ce que
certains ont rappelé les séparatismes
qui se voit tant sur l'échelle de de
notre pays de notre continent
que vaut plus proche dans le quartier
c'est en abordant tous ces échelons que
je vais pouvoir vous présenter nos
différents intervenants que qui vont
m'accompagner et que je vais pouvoir
interpeller d'abord rappeler un peu le
déroulé de ces tables rondes
je vais laisser la parole à nos
différents intervenants dans un premier
temps et puis dans deux en deuxième
temps vous pourrez les interpeller par
vos questions que vous pouvez dès le
départ posé que ce soit sur le field
facebook en dessous de cette vidéo ou
sur le fil de youtube et que donc en
deuxième partie de débat nous prendrons
au fur et à mesure j'ai le plaisir
d'abord dans
d'avoir dans cette table ronde franklin
go donc qui est le maire de fontaine qui
est quelqu'un qui est déjà un conquérant
un conquérant au sens électorale puisque
après des années des décennies d'extrême
gauche des génomes dit d'extrême gauche
sur la ville de fontaine il est allé la
conquérir électoralement il nous parlera
de toutes les conséquences dans la façon
aujourd'hui la modération qui l'a fait
preuve dans sa campagne lui permet de
faire revenir le public nous aurons su
trop dolce thomas qui est un ancien
garagiste j'aime à le rappeler qui a
toujours les mains dans le cambouis et
les mains dans le cambouis dans la
mairie d'hérouville saint clair depuis
2001 dont il est maire et vice-président
aussi en charge des politiques de la
ville et de la cohésion sociale à la
région normandie nous on suit le plaisir
d'avoir nathalie et limaces secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'éducation
prioritaire et rattaché auprès du
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports sylvie brunet
députée européenne et enfin jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec le
parlement
ancienne sénatrice ancienne
vice-présidente du sénat et vice
présidente du mouvement démocrate
donc comme je l'évoquais ce cette table
s'inscrit dans un temps spécifique aussi
d'après coville ou après des décennies
de centralisation aubaine nous avons
aussi
vécu une concentration géographique des
fragilités ce que ce soit dans certains
milieux urbains mais aussi dans certains
quartiers populaires et avec de grands
chantiers du coup de réappropriation de
ces territoires dans leur diversité
c'est aussi un affaiblissement parfois
du cadre républicain qu'il faut pouvoir
réimposer parfois par la force parfois
par le dialogue et parfois par l'action
et on y reviendra par exemple nathalie
éducative c'est aussi la réconciliation
des ententes entre des territoires
interdépendants mais qui parfois on
avait perdu conscience je pense
notamment entre les milieux ruraux et
les milieux urbains pour reprendre de la
cohérence et de la cohésion entre nos
territoires ruraux localiser aussi ces
interdépendances là où elles s'étaient
parfois distant du nom franck je vais de
céder tout de suite la parole frank ans
je disais tu es maire de fontaine en
isère dans la banlieue grenobloise
tut tut est confronté à une
problématique assez rapidement dans ce
début de mandat sur la nécessité de
pouvoir aller sortir des jeunes qui
étaient enfermés dans les quartiers
populaires de pouvoir leur donne les
réinsérer dans le tissu social qu'est ce
que tu peux nous en dire
alors je ne t'entends pas franck pour ma
part
petit souci technique est ce que ça peut
être un ancien terrain
c'est un petit souci on va peut-être
passer la parole à rodolphe et puis
franck reprendra la parole après
rodolphe est ce que tu m'entends est ce
que tu es ce que l'on entend si tu
parles
à nous essuyons les plâtres de cette
innovation technologique mais rodolphe
je ne t'entends
plus rodolphe
est ce que j'entends l'un de mes
camarades jacqueline evelyne cette ville
est ce que vous pouvez essayer de parler
la tentative on se rend tous est ce que
tu me suis
je t'entends jacqueline je t'entends le
cisco merveilleux et nathalie ces gens
pensent bon ouais tu m'entends vous
pouvez arrêter non je l'entends jean
pierre foucault outil si je t'entends la
police quand on frappe on va en profiter
explique donald votre tente de parler
france - oui là c'est bien je vous
entends tous ces parfaits ou c'est
merveilleux oui mais donc effectivement
je vais dans la lettre au maire de
fontaine donc en tête c'est une ville
qui est situé juste à côté de grenoble
une ville de 23 mille habitants et
qu'elle est gouvernée par une équipe
communiste depuis sur moi pour l'instant
je jacqueline vous entendez franck
ramenée à 2,2 oui franchement je
t'entends que j'ai les autres
intervenants ne s'entendent pas c'est la
régie peut aussi de regarder ça je suis
désolé fait alors un transbordement sur
un champ vous entre patrons ouais j'en
ai pour une bonne heure bien ok on
la régie va régler les problèmes
techniques pendant que tu commences je
te recèle la parole frank
oui je le disais donc maire de fontaine
depuis maintenant deux mois
fontaine c'est une ville qui est situé
juste à côté de grenoble
une ville qui a été gouverné pendant 75
ans donc depuis la guerre par une équipe
communiste effectivement un changement
souhaité par nos habitants puisqu'on a
été élu assez assez largement et on a
été confronté évidemment à de nombreuses
difficultés dans nos quartiers fontaine
est une ville populaire ville ouvrière
une ville qui a connu l'immigration je
suis moi-même petit fils d'immigrés
italiens et on a dû répondre pendant
cette campagne municipale aux
problématiques liées notamment à la
jeunesse dans les quartiers alors déjà
pourquoi on doit reconquérir
parce qu'on voit bien que de nombreuses
difficultés s'accumulent et les
difficultés elles sont de tous ordres
il ya des difficultés économiques on a
de grande précarité dans ces quartiers
on a des difficultés sociales on a dix
allmand on a des violences familiales
on a des difficultés liées aux problèmes
de sécurité on a du vandalisme monde a
des problème est lié aussi à
l'émancipation notre jeunesse et c'est
ce dernier point que je vais essayer
rapidement de développer effectivement
[Musique]
on s'est aperçu que malheureusement nos
jeunes souvent ne sortait pas de leur
quartier et on a essayé de répondre à
ces difficultés comment essayer de leur
faire comprendre comment on a essayé de
m'intéresser à autre chose que la vie de
leur quartier
alors comment on fait pour reconquérir
la réponse elle existe depuis des temps
j'allais dire reconquérir ses reprendre
possession d'un territoire s'est occupé
le territoire
donc on a souhaité nous récupérer le
terrain
amener de la présence sur le terrain et
notamment organisé et on l'a fait dès
notre élection organisée en lien avec
les associations des animations
organiser des événements culturels
organisés des concerts organisés du
théâtre organisé by cirque
l'objectif étant d'aller vraiment
directement à la rencontre des jeunes
parce qu'on s'est aperçu que
malheureusement certains jeunes ne
fréquentent pas les équipements
municipaux
par exemple on a une salle de spectacle
et on a énormément de jeunes
malheureusement des quartiers qu'ils ne
sont jamais allés dans leur salle des
spectacles donc le meilleur moyen
c'était d'organiser des événements qu'on
appelle hors les murs c'est à dire de
d'amener directement le spectacle dans
le quartier pour déjà montré un petit
peu ce qui se passe dans notre commune
et ensuite évidemment l'objectif c'est
de les attirer à l'intérieur de nos
structures
donc c'est vraiment le le travail que
nous on a fait ou les laisser des mots
dits n'est en rien dû recommencer
sérieux vim malheureusement on a vu peu
nombreux ton statut transfère pas partis
en vacances et dans ses objectifs
étaient vraiment aller alors en train
d'aller à leur contact louis jouvet ça
peut passer par des animations
quelquefois très simple je pense par
exemple à des matchs de foot pour
attirer notamment on va dire des jeunes
collégiens des jeunes lycéens mais je
crois que la reconquête des territoires
en tout cas pour ma part et on se
prosterne la jeunesse doit absolument
pas chez nous misons sur le terrain par
une présence des associations par une
présence des activités municipales par
une présence des services municipaux et
c'est ce qu'on a également p c'est à
dire que dans nos quartiers on a mis par
exemple notre espace jeunesse
on a mis nos inscriptions au
périscolaire à la cantine donc on a
ramené les services municipaux à
l'intérieur de nos quartiers parce qu'on
a besoin de désenclaver on a besoin de
montrer aux jeunes qui se passe beaucoup
de choses en dehors de leur quartier et
je crois que c'est vraiment ce qu'on
veut amener aux jeunes c'est à dire les
responsabiliser les émanciper aussi les
accompagner
par exemple un jeune qui voyagent un
jeune qui s'ouvre au monde
forcément il y aura peut-être plus envie
derrière d'aller à la conquête du monde
que j'ai 10 ans entre guillemets mais
voilà leur donner envie de faire autre
chose que de rester dans leur quartier
voilà en quelques mots
l'objectif en ce qui concerne la la
jeunesse
merci francs que pour ce mot et tu viens
de de l'évoquer largement la question de
l'avenir de nos jeunes dans la dynamique
qu'elle soit inséré d'insertion culturel
et bien entendu qui ont du mental
et puis se pose aussi la question d'un
certain nombre de quartiers en
difficulté sur lesquels des c'est une
constante et bien entendu 8 bon est
l'une des conditions nécessaires d'une
chanson qui ont rendu les conditions de
sécurité
un ministre de l'intérieur liés aux
mines est bien connue des tables des
gogos alors disait que le mouvement la
république points
beaucoup de ces gaps mais d'éviter
émergents c est à cet égard
rodolphe et tu tu as tu vu
impulsé un certain nombre d'actes
volontariste et tu as fait de
difficultés que tu voulais nous partager
et d'une détermination à l'égard de
cette problématique sécuritaire
oui bon je vous raconte bien tous donc
d'abord tout il ya des problématiques
techniques moi on va essayer de temps
n'arrangent et que tout le monde ment
comme tu le rappelait franck lavier
depuis 20 ans je suis à la mairie
d'hérouville donc j'essaye d'apporter de
contribuer à faire en sorte que cette
ville de 25 mille habitants puissent
fonctionner dans son développement
économique dans la culture dans
l'éducation surtout il et puis a
rapporté un cadre de reach et comme vous
savez comme dans beaucoup de villes de
france et où il a bénéficié d'un
programme ambitieux de rénovation
urbaine démolition reconstruction
cohésion sociale est ma priorité c'est
justement de travailler sur la mixité
sociale et je m'aperçois depuis
maintenant un an 200 du cros des
difficultés pour préserver le cadre de
vie est de faire en sorte cette villa
qui a effectivement beaucoup de risques
l'aise dans sa diversité et bien suisse
parfaite harmonie avec toutes les
actions que l'on remplace et je voulais
de particulièrement puisque jacques où
est la ministre l'a remercié et félicité
par rapport à ce qui a pu être fait au
travers des vacances apprenantes l'écolo
apprenant qu'il était important que les
villes qui avait des projets pour éviter
que les familles se retrouvent en
situation d'isolement halle avec la fin
avec la fermeture des frontières et on a
eu la chance d'avoir l'état à la fois la
drjs la préfecture de nous accompagner
dans toutes les perspectives d'un
accompagnement pendant le mois de
juillet et le mois d'août
donc tout ça pour rappeler qu'il ya eu
des choses qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement
ensuite la je voudrais en profiter avec
l'ensemble des auditeurs un peu mon
témoignage et et mon coup de gueule
parce que tu l'a rappelé alors j'ai
entendu francs que la situation est de
plus en plus délicate dans le cadre de
quand je parle de cohésion sociale et de
cadres vice et rétablir la sécurité dans
les quartiers
or depuis mon nom avant connaître les
élections mais surtout confinement
déconfinement une recrudescence de
délinquance et de violence de trafic et
de denain compte de plus pénible
et quand je dis ça gueule tu sais il a
commencé et le gouvernement m'a convié
pour rien c'est en parle que décrochage
de scolaires au chaud pige le subit de
plein fouet le décrochage scolaire n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui mais il ya 4 5 ans il
y a quelques années les maires et peu
informés lorsque déjà bien décrochage
scolaire entre 14 et 16 ans
ça nous permettait avec d'associations
dont il paie de faire du rappel à
l'ordre avec les familles or sous le
gouvernement
hollande m une circulaire est sorti chi
chi
rappelle que les maires ne sont plus
informés lorsqu'il y à un décrochage
scolaire prononcé et je suis scandalisé
quand la situation les uns les autres
sont confrontés et quand je pose la
question à certains de mes collègues des
maires ville et banlieue s'aperçoit
qu'on est dans la preuve même
problématique
donc quand on parle de la situation de
défilement de jeunes et de moins jeunes
eh bien on a un peu laissés pour compte
et j'ai envie de vous dire démerdez vous
donc on fait avec on se démerde
on essaye d'apporter des solutions car
comme vous le savez après 16 ans
l'éducation nationale n'est plus en
obligation de remettre en place les
outils d'euros scolarisation et donc ça
nous retombe dessus et on s'aperçoit que
le puits alors ça il va au bout de 6
voire un autre des jeunes vous n'êtes
pas plus et qui ont complètement
décrochés je voulais simplement rappeler
ce google
ensuite le maire il faut pas deux
exemples qui sont clients
j'ai une griffe à des effectifs de 12
policiers municipaux une chose souhaite
embaucher un policier national
il a commencé donc au mois de septembre
eh bien je ne peux pas le mettre sur le
terrain et due forme
parce que le ministre de l'intérieur ne
veut pas nous donner
comment tout le procès du satin bleu
prend le processus de de rapatrier comme
on dit les le policier national dans ce
qui veut dire que je veux embauché au
national pour compte dans la cnhi
territoriale et bien je suis obligé
d'attendre janvier
or kill complexe les effectifs et quand
j'appelle le ministère de l'intérieur at
sont pas d'image donc je suis un peu un
peu voire scandalisé sur la situation on
vous demande d
en des maires de ces deux terrains as tu
mets le désengagement de beaucoup de
services de l'état voire des
institutions mais on est complètement
seul et isolé et je trouve ça quand même
kafkaïen qu'on nous demande de faire est
derrière nous donne pas des moyens et
pour toi y ait une volonté locale
pouvoir le faire un autre exemple
cet été je la connaissais rien qui est
devenu un bureau de la police municipale
canicule on m'appelle le maire on de
fermer le bureau de la police de telle
heure à telle heure parce que il fait
trop chaud il fait trop chaud nous
verrons des clématites honneur mais le
repérage des fusibles de correspondre à
l'ampérage pour ou deux climatiseurs
donc je vous laisse apprécier réellement
la situation à laquelle le maire
je suis mais d'autres sont confrontés
donc donc c'est de carmoy m'exaspère ans
et je voudrais profiter de cette parole
pour dénoncer cette situation qui est
infernal alors on n'en fait pas partie
ce gouvernement on va bien on nous
demande on demande au gouvernement
actuel de régler toutes les
problématiques que les autres n'ont pu
faire on veut lui faire on le voit sur
plus de proximité avec sarkozy en
enlever d'un revers de la main le
décrochage scolaire comme ça avec les
jeunes bon bah dans tout ça on est
obligé de se débrouiller donc il y à une
recrudescence des finales ni le pardon
et supplée fillon qui est vraiment
vraiment prêt et puis moi je me dis
qu'on deviendra un peu parano qu'est-ce
qui se passe on essaye d'appeler nos
collègues depuis les banlieues à peu
dans la même configuration que nous et
il est vrai on est on
la situation est très grave
donc le témoignage
on va y arriver à s'en sortir mais je
peux vous garantir une situation où
certaines certaines institutions dégage
complètement de toute responsabilité sur
les coques ans qu'on habite mais qu'on
nous donne les moyens de revenir
aujourd'hui et bien dès qu'on aura plus
le policier peu j'attends maintenant
semaine le plus gros charge de ce col en
plus qu'avant la voix s'expliquer sur je
ne veux pas d'un sujet il ya quand même
eu tendance à essayer de récupérer et de
reconquérir putois
si on n'y prête pas garde ça risque de
basculer en france les séparatistes
j'aime pas trop ce terme depuis cette
année on va changer les termes en mon
avis mais avec les uns et les autres
mais il ya encore une situation assez
dramatique
non parce que voilà un peu mon
témoignage
beaucoup de reprendre s'il le faut avec
la justice la chaîne pénale qui n'est
pas adaptée à tous les niveaux c'est
pourquoi on le rappelle c'est lui qui
écrit il faut aussi nous ne valeur des
contrats est bien aussi de s'inscrire
sur une alerte d d d d attention
particulière pour faire en sorte que la
chaîne fonctionne qu'elle fonctionne de
façon je prédis radicale mais de façon
exemplaire pour
assurer les habitants moi j'appelle pas
la justice la pile de protéger comment
peut-on protéger les gens qui demandent
à travailler à vivre en paix et kim a
commis dix soirs sont emmerdés excusez
moi de l'expression pour retourne
intervient nous mais on voit bien c'est
hyper hyper défensif merci on leur donne
pour ce témoignage eu deux terrains
comme tu es habitué à nous les livrer
c'est vrai que tu mentionnait la
problématique de l'applicabilité des
peines dans d'ailleurs je salue le fait
que le gouvernement sur soit largement
saisie et et je rejoins tout à fait ton
appel à dire que avis rangs démocrates
dans la famille qui est de penser qu'il
y avait un autre c'est aussi faire appel
à cette nécessité de fermeté
républicaine
cette ferme et i2 républicaine qui
permet de protéger les plus fragiles et
qui permet aussi de dire dans la
construction de notre vivre ensemble et
je pense que nous y sommes attachés
comme démocrate il n'ya que ce n'est pas
là la loi du plus fort qui doit primer
la loi du plus aux audacieux dans sa
façon d'envahir le territoire au
bénéfice des autres et c'est vrai qu'on
voit bien comment dans les milieux
urbains en particulier ces enchères va
autrement humains démographique peuvent
parfois créer des confrontations très
violente et pour livrer un témoignage
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui dans notre vie
on est vraiment à devoir prévenir une
partie de la population pour éviter que
se constitue y compris des des milices
parfois et je vous assure qu'on en est
là dans certains de nos quartiers
populaires et on ne peut pas un
démocratie envisager que la république
ne soit plus celle qui fasse foi parce
que sinon d'autres systèmes vont se
mettre en place et que nous ne mettrons
pas ce que tu évoques toutefois est que
on retrouve aussi dans l'interview
fonction franck c'est la nécessité
d'avoir une approche transversale dans
cette reconquête des territoires qu'elle
qui intègre à la fois la dimension là on
va parler de la sécurité mais tu as
aussi parler des problématiques
éducatives
franck a parlé d' à la fois de problèmes
éthiques culturelles sportives
associatives
pour d'insertion vous avouer que quand
on a défini les contours par exemple de
ma délégation avec mon père c'est
insertion emploi éducation université
c'était justement pour pouvoir amener un
certain nombre de jeunes dans des
dynamiques positives en faisant appel à
cette transversalité à cette mise en
synergies d'un certain nombre d'éléments
et ça ramène assez directement à donner
la parole à nathalie à madame la
secrétaire d'état
vous êtes sûr vous avez eu l'honneur et
je vous en félicite je te félicite
nathalie de pouvoir voir confier cette
mission de l'éducation prioritaire qui
est cher à notre famille celle de
l'éducation en général mais aussi de
l'éducation en tant que ferment
d'égalité entre eux entre les
populations d'égalité déchets et des
chances et c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu
majeur pour nous la politique première
la merde fixer la politique éducative
donc mission importante que que tu as et
tu vas pouvoir nous dire
finalement quel est le sens même d'avoir
dans cette politique éducative des
cibles prioritaires
justement cette démarche se regarder des
territoires et comment tu l'envisagent
merci françois xavier d'abord est on
tente anglais est ce que tu as entendu
les intervenants présents donc d'abord
en france ce matin où le mental est
particulier
je vis damman et de alors prêt davis
spécifiquement les i c'est une première
sous la vème rien illustre la jour dix
ans la ministre veut lutter mais même
les était donc matt et le goûter très
sain décrit donc commencer bientôt pour
france 2 très heureuse à venir ici
présent est vraiment l'aider tous les
territoires carte mais c'est aussi là
c'est que si par exemple lisbonne j'ai à
nouveau très toute collectivité et
[Musique]
bascula jeu qu'est ce que c'est moi
c'est le nathalie n'a jamais su que
j'étais pour rêver je puisse régler avec
toi un petit problème technique parce
que vivant ton propos arrivent de façon
un peu lâché par moment et du coup on
perd un peu le fil de de ton
intervention mais on va te reprendre un
tout petit peu plus tard si tu veux bien
je vais donner en attendant la parole a
suivi
sylvie brunet qui pendant un certain
temps qui nous vient des bouches du
rhône députée européenne qui est membre
de la commission de l'emploi et des
affaires sociales
la reconquête des territoires c'est
aussi la nécessité de pouvoir anticiper
on a évoqué des volets éducatifs
sécuritaire culturel associatif mais
c'est aussi une problématique économique
parce que bien souvent un territoire qui
décroche ou l'ensemble des sociétés et
d'une communauté de vie peut décrocher
c'est une communauté de vie qui parfois
va décrocher sur le plan économique
parce qu'on n'aura pas suffisamment
anticipé les évolutions tant des
secteurs d'activités qui sont qui s'y
développent ou les évolutions plus
globale de la société qui auront un
impact spécifique sur ce territoire
tout le monde connaît l'histoire
malheureuse de la chute de l'emploi dans
le nord de la france après la période de
de vie autour du charbon qui a été la
sienne et comment les mutations le
défaut d'accompagnement des mutations
économiques a pu parfois faire chuter
des territoires le parlement européen a
pris l'habitude est fortement impliqué
les tue un certain nombre d'initiatives
pour nous permettre et on voit bien dans
le pot vide à combien c'est nécessaire
d'anticiper et d'accompagner ces
transformations et je sais que là dessus
et une expertise à nous partager dans
cette vocation économique à anticiper
les chu des territoires et à nous
empêcher d'avoir à reconquérir des
territoires mais aussi d'en accompagner
la reconquête par le la fibre économique
bien merci font donc bonjour bonjour
mesdames les ministres et bien des
parlements européens notamment avec le
car les normes conditions ni un peu rare
il le devait vraiment axes stratégiques
alors fendu de en train de perdre en
cours va ensuite réparti différemment
ensuite six semaines deux parties et eux
ils ont une production de charbon et
tout mais ça fait d'autres une
production vers la dhr univers harmonie
alors c'est armé avait aussi un pur
milliards et enfin de près ou en
compagnie d'un guide
alors justement arc d'avoir moins six
pales tenu à nous accorder tout terrain
s'ils ont des sous et que uniquement
qu'on second des normes européennes
toronto un responsable la vraie nature
des rapports l'intérieur ont juste qu'il
va mais la france a dépensé
emploi j'ai l'exemple à côté de chez moi
même plus de sens et là deux formations
ne pas la nier haute de production est
ce qu'ils sentent moi non en plus d'être
un spectable d'investissement plus du
gros lourd a fini la crise au moins on
avait pu mais uniquement à l'occasion
des sujets qui mettront le garant c'est
un des jeunes les missions locales
alors tu en auras l'occasion le web que
tu as donc développé ça tout à l'heure
puisque nous avons un certain nombre de
conclure des problématiques d'apprentis
cette chère mais je pense qu'on
reviendra sur cet aspect là dedans dans
la partie question c'est si ça te va
je vais céder la parole maintenant à à
même le ministre jacqueline gros merci
d'abord de votre présence
jacqueline vous êtes vous avez été une
élue de terrain des décennies durant la
conquête et la reconquête des
territoires
j'ai envie de dire c'est le travail de
toute une vie ou aujourd'hui vous
l'exercez au plus haut niveau de
responsabilité directe qui soit ça a été
votre travail depuis 2010 est en
particulier
vous avez toujours été au chevet j'ai
envie de dire des particules
territoriaux vous avez pu les exercer
par exemple en alsace ou en corse d'une
part mais aussi dans les problématiques
d'aménagement du territoire et et de et
de prise en compte des faits spécifiques
de la ruralité auquel je sais que vous
êtes attaché mes dents suite à l'entente
de ses prises de parole je redonnerai la
voilà à nathalie après bien entendu sur
l'aspect éducatif est prioritaire des
clés de problèmes seront réglés mais
voilà sur cette approche cohérente qui
est la voûte
que vouliez vous nous témoignez merci
françois xavier bonjour à toutes et à
tous
moi j'ai un retour mais quand on entend
très bien
est-ce que vous m'accordez que ça va
très bien parfaitement
alors alors j'ai d'abord vous dire que
le ronge
à tous il faut le rappeler
quand nous sommes arrivés au
gouvernement nous avons connu france
extrêmement comment dire
centré sur des inégalités territoriales
et là dessus développé dans le mandat de
landes
et dans les mandats il y a eu comme vous
le savez à la foire de politique
entraîné le recul des services publics
sur les territoires il y a eu à la fois
une métropolisation ça et je dirais que
ont renforcé ce sentiment ou
s'intéresser davantage à l'avenir et pas
suffisamment à la campagne a donné un
sentiment d'abandon de certains et nous
avec eux il ya vu des crises comme la
série des jaunes a mis en exergue
sentiment qui n'était pas qu'un
sentiment d'ailleurs inégalités
territoriales est donc aujourd'hui
synthétique c'est de répondre nouvelle
donne politique pour la reconquête des
territoires quoi s'agit il s'agit pas
trop paul quatre quartiers difficiles
qu'ont mondiales record il y a de la
ruralité et je vérité p il s'agit at-il
dit
pour accompagner les élèves au hainaut
pas inverse parce que la france et six
fractures et que je pense qu'il faut
avoir comme il est cuit il faut
s'appuyer sur la réalité des territoires
avec des grandes villes nationales
de solidarité mais il faut partir des et
s'appuyer sur les élus locaux
tout à l'heure on redonne pas parler
qu'elle était jolie initiative militaire
que le ministère de l'éducation
nationale fait exactement puisque allez
voir on ne peut rien sans nez technique
municipal leurs fonctionnaires
territoriaux ou leur équipe
le social les associations le gag et ça
donne l'ensemble des vacances
apprenantes mairie c'est à sa pension
d'état financement et et les
collectivités dans les halles à
s'organiser
c'est quelque chose de c'est la raison
pour laquelle la nouvelle donne vraiment
mais et accompagner les projets et a
vaincu les cris des territoires c'est
dans d'autres domaines
je pourrais citer acheteurs de lille
je pourrais citer territoires ddt
investi car général que nous avons une
classe et bientôt les villes de demain
que je vais lancer avec le couvent c'est
donc répondre aux besoins et avec des
politiques qui s'appuie sur des projets
locaux donnent de grandes villes comme
le faut par exemple reconquérir le coeur
des vignes n est pour une grande idée
qui était juste qu'avait lancé mon
prédécesseur chat le mesa elle était
juste des départs orange
cependant ce cadre de la politique de la
vie de la politique action coeur de
ville
non c'est leur projet que nous
accompagnons voilà là dessus la deuxième
chose c'est que naturellement la crise
de la commune a réalisé par dessus les
inégalités et il est importante
davant qui est des marques viennent ici
non seulement comment dire corrigé les
cuisses la crise sociale mais il ya
aussi trempé et vient corriger qualité
alors comme vous le savez il ya 100
milliards et je salue au passage
ma collègue députée européenne sylvie
brunet parce que 40% de ces fonds il ya
des requins car viennent des comptes
européens enfin que cette enveloppe est
la vertu le négocier quand je crée
négocier et donc des moyens
moi je suis élu depuis très longtemps
comme vous l'avez rappelé pour une
valeur de la première fois que je vois à
partir d'hier aux élus est remonté les
projets à ce qu'il y a l'argent là on à
rester avec lens d'habitude c'est plutôt
des projets à celui des amendes de
moyens là évidemment il ya beaucoup de
moyens et
ce plan de relance devra être mis en
place en deux ans donc il faut je fais
passer le message que les élus se
mobilisent
évidemment en moi y ait des doutes ils
sont prêts dans tel ou tel jeu c'est
bien maintenant il faut que dans lequel
ado l'inspecter et un festival maximum
mais voilà bon et puis nous allons
terminer par sa trop longue les futures
lois la doua 3d décentralisation
déconcentration et différenciation
alors peut-être commencer par dire papa
c'est le pays et l'eau c'est-à-dire
profil ou organiques en premier ça va
être le 2 novembre au sénat et ensuite à
l'assemblée nationale s'il parle de
l'expérimentation taxe puisque nous
allons permettre nous allons faciliter
l'expérimentation sont les devoirs et
surtout c'est une politique marshall en
moi eh bien on arrête l'obligation que
cette politique s'applique à toute la
france avec aujourd'hui
l'expérimentation au bout d'un certain
temps quand on peut la poursuivre
laisse-moi au les temps sur l'ensemble
est gris voire soit on arrête et donc ça
ça sera une modification très important
de ces événements vraiment reconnaître
la spécificité des territoires et donc
c'est mais l'expérimentation devient de
la différence
et puis c'est bien des heures et nous
aurons des transferts de compétences ne
pas être longue
tu points vous pourrez madame la
ministre prendre la parole et c'est vrai
que ce que vous évoquez de respect de la
différenciation et des différences entre
territoires je me rappelle que c'est
quelque chose que vous évoquiez déjà il
y a un certain nombre d'universités de
rentrée du mouvement démocrate avec
françois bayrou et les heureux de voir
qu'on peut avancer là dessus vous avez
aussi eu renier un contexte nous devons
pouvoir croquons un lion et les yeux qu
sont très sensibles dans un moment où
ils se sentent fragilisés attaqués avec
une violence à l'égard des élus dans
l'exercice de leur mandat sous toutes
ses formes ce qui est particulièrement
forte jeudi par exemple candidat je
n'avais pas vécu une campagne locale
comme celle que nous avons vécue c'est
la première fois que pour ma part en
tout cas je suis amené à devoir porter
plainte pour eux reçu des menaces de
mort répétées dans une dans une campagne
électorale et nous devons et je vous en
remercie
à voir ce message de solidarité de
soutien qui font vivre nos territoires
je vais je vais redonner la parole à
nathalie et limaces ou les secrétaires
d'état je ne sais pas si on a pu régler
les problèmes techniques
on va attendre
moi je t'entends mais ben ali j'espère
que ça sera pas coupée mais vas-y tu
peux y aller est ce que tu fais bien
ou synthétiques en fait c'était à chaud
régulier donc on avait des pas mal de
retours sur le fait que c'était pas
audible pour un certain temps donc
peut-être synthétise que tu avais essayé
mais je pense que tu peux apprendre
depuis le début visiblement c'était très
haché très bien donc g10 éducation
prioritaire république qu'il a été créé
le comprimé une forte du président de la
république de lutter contre toutes les
inégalités ont réussi la type s quand
inégalités sociales mais aussi sur la
méthode pour le monde pour de france de
l'éducation priori très locaux je vais
je vais parce que j'ai envie de dire ce
type mais l'éducation priori l'équpe et
v4 et pubs on retrouve de l'éducation
prioritaire avec des formes et les
objectifs qui sont différents sinon les
os et donc je vais l'ensemble stats et
tout s'est fracturé la fin prêt faire un
diagnostic ou possible être à l'école
jeanne mis en place un certain nombre de
bureaux à louer la crise sanitaire est
passée par là évidemment sur et de crise
sociale le fruit du revenu
en sortie de confinement finale je lui
ai dit d'aller rattraper les décrocheurs
école l'odyssée le dos à dos l'ont été
il ya eu un succès l'écolo apprenantes
les stages d'abord l'occasion desquelles
on a vu on avait totalement que rue du
jeu donne un chiffre qui parle de dix
mille îles et de réussite cette année
250 mm ces stages depuis une semaine la
rentrée scolaire c'est la folie pendant
toute cette période
en filmant et notamment être s'est plus
difficilement validé ils ont repris le
téléphone chercher les familles est loin
du compte d'ailleurs pratique est
beaucoup plus efficace comme ça que le
mot au cloud mais le cahier des élèves
g10 et au site nous venons déjà été
mitigé et que je pense en particulier
aux c'est une table à une écoute qui se
crée autour de lui autour de l'église
tout ce moment dans l'école et au relais
comme lé monde perçoit que c'était
effectif ce dispositif les dernières
mises en place en début d'année et c'est
l'alliance de territoire l'état les
collectivités territoriales
l'exemple bien évidemment
les éducateurs les médiateurs sociaux le
sport où elle a rien le sport culture
des actes créé autour du jeune homme
pour pour les accompagner
c'est bien mais c'est bien la norme
alors évidemment c'est un jeu attendu le
compte peut être pas vraiment j'ai
entendu je vais passer parce que non les
maires notre pas seuls dans la méthode
marche évidemment un show davantage
maintenant vraiment réussi sur le
décrochage scolaire les enfants
je suis le cadet des enfants les colons
j'ai trois ans et ça se poursuit -
formation alors chez nous mais cela nous
chante ce que nous et dieu rodolphe sur
cette nécessité de cette lutte contre le
décrochage qui inaugure aussi quitter
l'île
mais ça n'est plus nadery j'en profite
plus que tu abordes la problématique
aussi des décrocheurs évoqué tout à
l'heure rodolphe nous avons quelques
interventions d'internautes et ça me
permet comme ça de de commencer à
intégrer un peu les internautes dans
notre discussion avec notamment ramage
qui nous dit qu on a eu un super projet
au niveau local dans sa ville avec les
décrocheurs en les réintégrant par les
biais du loup et désirs
mais où ils nous interpellent en disant
l'éducation nationale n'a pas joué le
jeu
alors j'imagine pas toujours on voit
aussi beaucoup de travail autour des
dppr eux qui est qui et produit des
programmes de réussite éducative
comment est ce que vous envisagez et les
quelques questions comme ça
d'internautes sur cet aspect là
travailler sur le lien renforcé le lien
et l'interaction entre les acteurs de
l'éducation nationale au premier plan de
cette démarche de reconquête et les et
les autres acteurs locaux de tissu
associatif des centres sociaux des
mairies etc
là où parfois il ya un clivage un
fonctionnement en silo qui est un peu
ressenti qui empêche ses mises en
synergie
merci tout cela est fini mais peut-être
que c'est un peu difficile pour les
esprits le rô le des types de créer du
lien ou les autres peut que l'ensemble
notamment les associations ou cremona
république de ce qui aujourd'hui
[Musique]
de l'année dernière mettant très
fortement être nous allons miser
séminaire ensemble des acteurs autant de
récupérer les bonnes pratiques et puis
surtout l'objet de l'eau c'est qui qui
je suis au passage à une ordination de
mal
l'ensemble merci je vais redonner un peu
la parole à aarau dolf et et franck sur
ces aspects un peu de mise en synergie
dont il est vrai et là j'en témoigne
comme un jeune adjoint à l'éducation
entre autres choses les chantiers sont
encore très vaste rolf hug
oui oui je voudrais complété vous
confirmer des propos de compagnie dont
certaines villes ont bénéficié qui
m'attend permettre en train de
rassembler l'ensemble des acteurs au
courant même social éducatif de la ville
et avec des organismes
il est vrai véritablement dispositif
d'accompagnement éducatif de touristes
dit culture ou ô combien de sportifs
c'est qu'on arrive à travailler en forme
était pris 2
de constant mutuelle et bien on arrive à
bout les dignes la cité être marrant
pour c'est l'idée même de tête que le
collaborateur
cette cohésion de son anticipation et
mairie on va y arriver mais axé mes
collègues pour faire en sorte que les
pics d'orientation et ayant la chance on
a besoin de tenir une fois les acteurs
de terrain des verts des associations et
d'éducation nationale avec la région qui
a pris complétant ses murs des
mouvements jeu d'orientation et des
métiers quand même des courants est
essentielle donc voilà tout ça pour dire
que lorsqu'il ya véritablement à 1 me +9
chef de file avec on peut y arriver et
je trouve bien quand même
pour autant perdu parce que je subis des
collègues suisses aient un peu la
politique a été mise en place
quand je parle mais les jeunes qui
n'était pas repéré d'autres pieds et
comment on les abandonne après + 20 il
ya des choses qui sont faites mais ne
prennent pas en permanence en ligne avec
les yeux moment par moments on y met
dans lequel on vit
et donc non pas voilà la cité du gant le
pays où tout ce qui gravite autour de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent un axe
majeur pour la cohésion de nos il ya un
certain nombre de questions là des
internautes je prends notamment
christine chevalier qui travaillent en
mission locale est occupée b qui dit les
emplois francs sur son secteur il ya eu
aucune démarche locale pour informer les
employeurs dont complot aucun emploi
francs
mais je là dessus pour par rapport à ce
que tu viens d'évoquer et je vais donner
un peu la parole à franck sur cet aspect
là c'est vrai que régulièrement et je
vis aussi beaucoup sur ma commune on a
parfois des difficultés à ce que les
acteurs locaux et à commencer par les
maires puissent s'approprier l'ensemble
des dispositifs c'est à dire qu'il peut
y avoir des initiatives nationales qui
sont pris leurs déclinaisons dans les
territoires parce qu'il est qu'ils sont
censés les portes et les 1000 maîtres en
un c'est pas toujours aussi évident en
fonction aussi de leur niveau de
connaissance de ces dispositifs c'est
vrai que y compris parfois les services
ont du mal à s'en approprier et dans la
démarche insertion la complexité ou la
multiplicité ou la profusion de
dispositifs très intéressant dans leurs
conceptions parfois trouve ses limites
justement que du fait que de cette
profusion résulte une difficulté de
l'ensemble des acteurs à tous
s'approprier ces à s'approprier tous ces
dispositifs nous avons bien souvent dire
que les jeunes hommes en haut niveau de
l'état
mais il ya là un chaînon manquant qui ne
se fait pas et qu'il n'y aurait pas de
leur synergie franc qui a aussi une
expérience territoriale avant d'avoir
été maire puisqu'il a été aussi
directeur de service dans une
collectivité auparavant connais bien ces
problématiques
comment tu laborde dès le début de son
mandat de maire si tu nous entends
france
oui exactement tenue tu le disais j'ai
été directeur général voulait surtout
faire l'exemple est alors arrivé cette
semaine une réunion avec l'inspecteur de
deux d'école et 17 fallait et on a
échangé ensemble pour un contrat qu'on a
tous partagé et que dans nos écoles
on a été confronté à de nombreuses
familles qu'elles quoi
non à la contre attaque en berne ou
simplement à des parents qui sont en
incapacité de voir à la maison et on
s'est posé la question de savoir comment
il répond bien sûr
ensemble puisque nous avons à la fois
l'excitation fonctionne à l'autre dans
les directeurs d'école et bien c'est
triste mais aussi des f&a répondre à
cette problématique puisque en tant que
mère mon objectif c'est bien sûr
reconnaît un maximum de réussite voire
atteindre leur rêve et de venise et donc
la municipalité pour la banque une
première et c'est ce qu'on avait déjà
proposé pendant la campagne il a proposé
au directeur d'école à partir de
maintenant il va t elle mettre en place
sur le court périscolaire du soutien
scolaire
ça n'était pas le cas avant il y avait
déjà des dispositifs qui au travers
l'éducation nationale sans faute à mort
ou tapissés à des dispositifs lui
également porté par la mjc par des fonds
spéciaux mais voit traverser que malgré
politique là on avait des enfants
il doit rentrer chez eux et la bible à
la maison voir accompagner dans leurs
devoirs dans l'apprentissage des lauzon
donc où il nous paraissait important
vraiment à cette problématique lie à
notre commune puisqu'on est une commune
brière est dit alors avec eux à bord par
des migrations et donc nous la commune
et e
testez déjà sur d'autres hautes écoles
ou des cars scolaires sont complets et
si évidemment secours fonctionne et si
on veut collaborer du pas bien le maître
9 sur l'ensemble de nos écoles à partir
du mois de septembre 2021 donc voilà je
voulais parler de cette expo qui peut
concrètement à mettre en place
bien sûr ces troubles un peu d'argent
mais l'objectif vraiment c'est pour voir
un maximum de chances à l'ensemble de
nos enfants voilà au lycée pour faire le
parcours de leur choix et puis plus tard
d'une birman obtenir le métier de leur
rêve c est ça prouve aussi
problématiques en lien avec les domaines
si aujourd'hui nous sommes actuellement
dans les quartiers sont là à traîner ne
pas voir
qui parce que on n'a peut-être pas
répondu à ces coulées matic tôt dans la
partie
j'en prends tous évidemment de l'école
est à mon avis le lieu au moment où on
peut agir pour voulais juste venir
surtout avec l'arrivée de plus tôt merci
franck et je vais devoir malheureusement
conclure et je m'excuse
sylvie on va pas avoir le temps de
revenir sur le volet formation
apprentissage faire les aléas techniques
ont un peu contraint notre notre temps
et on n'a pas pu prendre toutes les
questions et donc je m'excuse aussi
auprès des internautes
c'est vrai tu as parfaitement raison et
je veux finir aussi là-dessus francs que
tu rodolphe a aussi évoqué cette
compétence orientation qui a été
affectée aux régions territorialisée qui
doit nous permettre de travailler aussi
dès le plus jeune âge en lien avec en
travaillant sur la parentalité qui sont
les premiers acteurs de l'orientation
qui permettent de prendre très tôt les
problèmes à la racine à la base
s'assurer que les savoirs fondamentaux
sont pris mais aussi pouvoir travailler
tôt sur et savoir travailler sur une
orientation positive une orientation
professionnelle qui soit choisi une
orientation qui nous permettent de
valoriser les métiers qui a la foi donne
une vraie salaires une autonomie une
émancipation sens sans fantasme ni
frustration et c'est aussi en prenant ça
et c'est un constat qu'on a fait avec
eux nos missions locales avec les
acteurs de l'insertion que on pourra le
faire et pour ça il faut remettre de la
transversalité et moi je le dis c'est
aujourd'hui un des grands chantiers que
j'ai entreprise c'est de faire
travailler des missions locales avec mes
collèges mais y compris avec ceux des
directions éducatif qui travaille auprès
auprès des parents qui ont leurs enfants
en primaire pour petit à petit forme et
les parents qui seront ceux qui feront
l'orientation de demain souvent de leurs
enfants et de travailler comme ça tout
au long de la vie sur cette orientation
tout au long de la vie et si sylvie
pourrait nous en parler aussi de cette
nécessité comme ça d' accompagner tout
au long de la vie la formation la
réorientation la compétence l'évolution
dans le métier pour aussi que ce soit
des outils de lutte
de décrochage qui peuvent se faire tout
au long de la vie y compris quand on
n'est qu'un qu'elle génère et on le voit
aujourd'hui dans la période
coville ou beaucoup de carrières se
retrouvent haché et tout cela doit nous
permettre d'anticiper le décrochage de
certains territoires leur paupérisation
leurs difficultés
donc c'est à la fois un travail de soins
que nous ont très bien décrit notamment
jacqueline gourault mais aussi
d'anticipation et de prévention c'est
surtout ces vecteurs là qu'il faut
pouvoir travailler
j'appuierai franck sur un dernier mot
pour te dire je suis ravi que tu
illustre aussi ici avec jacqueline avec
tous les autres le fait que un vieux
mouvement comme le nôtre c'est aussi un
mouvement qui arrive à faire monter de
nouvelle génération d'élus on a beaucoup
de jeunes élus de jeunes mères qui ont
été élus au modem c'est ces dernières
années et je sais que avec des personnes
comme toi
avec l'expérience de de jacqueline et de
tant d'autres on pourra faire ce travail
à la fois de transmission et de
reconquête des territoires dans la durée
je vous remercie tous pour votre
participation et je cède du coup la
place à la prochaine table ronde
merci